ce sera
en son centre
le cristal de vérité la source de toute
vie
[Musique]
l'esc excès sont corrompus
à présent l'obscurcissement menace notre
monde qu'est ce que c'est
l'obscurcissement
voix par toi même
sherman
j'ai eu une vision
tulle et trop d'histoires c'était bien
réel
[Musique]
tout ce que l'esc excess nous disent
depuis si longtemps n'est que mensonge
et maintenant tout le monde et toutes
choses
est en péril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec moi unissons-nous enfin contre
notre véritable ennemi
l'esc excess les sketches et son terme
la résistance en sang
[Musique]
tu es sûr que ça ira non
mais je garde espoir
[Applaudissements]
gagner la puissance d'un
l'obscurcissement
l'espoir est fragile
précieux
[Musique]
combat de crâne de cristal
autrefois paix de dieu
et aujourd'hui retrouvé et facilement
terreau p
[Musique]
je ne pense pas que tout redeviendra
comme avant c'est vrai ce sera encore
mieux qu'avant
[Musique]